for hundreds of years Pirates Vikings
and Navy boats have battled for every
inch of the seven seas and now the
battle is spread to the shore
new captain on the Navy ship this year
and we're coming for you you better be
ready to baby-headed prepare to get wet
with your own blood
[Music]
deep in the Australian Outback you'll
find Alice Springs
it's a town straddling miles of desert
and the river Todd well river is a
strong word because the Todd it spends
most of the Year dry
it's on this scorching riverbed that the
town hosts Henley on Todd the world's
only dry Riverboat race
unsurprisingly
on Todd is just a crazy day of crazy
races and activity in the draw riverbed
this this Dry River bed here of the Todd
River here in the middle of Australia in
central Australia in Alice Springs back
here I reckon it was in 1962 red Smith
and and Furby's rotarian mates they were
having having some beers and trying to
work out how to do a fundraiser they
came up this idea of having a boat race
in the Todd River and then they thought
well okay we do that but but how are we
going to move these boats and red said
now what we'll do is we'll cut the
bottoms out of them and we'll run inside
them
there's so many events going on on the
day
the finale of the event is the Battle of
the boats they're actually proper boats
but underneath the boats is generally
it's a four-wheel drive and that's how
it's powered it's the craziest thing you
can imagine of three boats one we've got
the Navy two we've got the Pirates and
three we've got the Vikings
let's meet the teams
the Navy is the best boat and crew in
this battle we've got the best moral
fiber we've got the the best standards
we're disciplined and we would die on
the battlefield for each other
on the pirate ship we've got
52 cannons we've got a gunpowder match
we put the match in the bottom we pack
it with an unmilled flower and along
with that we have a lot of water bombs
Vikings have got to be the best team
because we're not afraid to go to battle
we're probably the goofiest so we'll
just run around town and make people
laugh and do silly shenanigans
This is Our Winning trophy from last
year I don't plan for this trophy to go
anywhere this year we'll be drinking out
of it again
[Music]
foreign
let the battle commence
final battle is the greatest water fight
that you could ever experience in your
life
[Music]
colorful Affair it is a loud Affair and
it is a very very messy affair
[Music]
the very final decision of the day is
who wins the battle of the boats and
that's decided by the crowd whoever
applauds you know the loudest
parents are victorious in this year's
Henley on Todd both battle
s winning the battle boat spectacular is
the greatest feeling
you jump off that boat completely elated
and you just celebrate with your
teammates it is unbelievable
[Applause]
[Music]
make sure you like subscribe and share
with friends